all right good afternoon and welcome to
the last class of how to start a startup
so this is a little bit different than
every other class every other class has
been things that you should be thinking
about in general at the beginning of a
startup and today we're going to talk
about things that you want to think
about for a while in fact you shouldn't
but since I'm not going to get to talk
to most of you again before you get to
sort of post product market fit stage I
want to just give you the list of things
that you need to think about as your
startup scales and the list of the
things that usually founders fail to
make the transition on so these are the
topics were going to talk about but
again all of these things are things
that are not writing code or talking to
users which means with a few exceptions
that I'll try to note you can ignore
them until after you have product market
fit most of these things for most
companies become important between
months 12 and 24 but it's really more
about stage than anything else these are
things that usually hit around 25 people
and definitely post product market fit
so just write these down somewhere and
look back at them when you get there so
the first area we're going to talk about
is management at the beginning of a
company there is no management and this
actually works really well before 20 or
25 employees most companies are
structured with everyone reporting to
the founder it's totally flat and that's
really good and that's what you want and
at that stage that is the optimal way
for product that's the optimal structure
for productivity but the thing that
tricks people is that when when lack of
structure fails it fails all at once and
so what works totally fine at 20
employees is from zero to 20 employees
is disastrous at 30 and so you want to
be aware that this transition will
happen and you don't actually need to
make the structure complicated in fact
you shouldn't all you need is for every
employee to know who their manager is
and every and there should be exactly
one and every manager should know who
their direct reports are you want to
ideally cluster people on teams that
make sense of course but the most
important thing is that there's just
clear reporting structure and that
everyone knows what it is and if you
want to make changes to it
we'll understand how to make changes or
to hire someone clarity and simplicity
are the most important things here but
failing to do it is really bad so
because it works in the early days to
have no structure at all and because it
sort of feels cool to have no structure
many companies are like we're going to
try this crazy new management theory and
have no structure what you want to do is
innovate on your product and your
business model management structure is
not where I would recommend trying to
innovate so don't make the mistake of
having nothing but don't make the other
mistake of having something super
complicated a lot of people fall into
this trap where they think it's like you
know people feel cool if they're
someone's manager and if they're just an
employer they don't feel cool so people
come up with these convoluted circular
matrices management structures where you
report to this person for this thing and
this person for that thing this person
for that thing but you know actually
this person reports to you for this
thing that's a mistake too so don't
don't try to innovate here this is the
first instance of an important shift in
companies or in the founders job the
four product market fit your only job
that matters is to build a great product
or in your number one job is to build a
great product as the company grows and
about this you know 25 or so employee
size your main job shifts from building
a great product to build integrated
company and it stays there for the rest
of your time and this is probably the
biggest shift in being a founder that
ever happens there are four failure
cases we see all the time as founders
become managers so I want to talk about
the four most common ones the first one
is being afraid to hire senior people in
the early days of a start-up hiring
senior people is usually a mistake you
just want people that get stuff done and
and the willingness to work hard and
aptitude matters more than experience as
the company starts to scale and about
this time when you have to put in place
a basic management structure it is
actually valuable to have senior people
on the team you know executives that
have built companies before it and
almost all founders after the first time
they hire a really great executive and
that executive takes over big pieces of
business and just makes them happen the
founder says wow I wish I had done that
earlier but everybody makes this mistake
and it wastes too long to do this so
don't don't be afraid to hire senior
executives the second mistake is hero
mode so I will use the example of say
someone that runs a customer service
team sometimes the customer service team
they want to lead by example this starts
from a good place it's the extreme of
leading by example it's saying you know
what I want my team to work really hard
rather than problem to work hard I'm
going to set an example now I'm going to
work 18 hours a day and I'm going to
show people how to get a lot of tickets
done but then the company starts growing
also they have the normal discomfort of
assigning a lot of work to other people
so the company starts growing and the
ticket volume keeps going up and now
there you have to do like 19 hours a day
and the 20 hours a day and just
obviously not working but they won't
stop and hire people because they're
like if I stop even for one day we're
going to get behind on tickets the only
way to get out of here on mode in this
case is to say you know what we're going
to get behind on tickets for 2 or 3
weeks because I'm going to go off and
I'm gonna hire 3 more support team
members and I've calculated based off of
our growth rate that this is going to
last this long and next time I'm not
gonna make the same mistake I'll get
ahead of it and hire again but you
actually have to make a trade-off you
actually have to say you know what I
need to hire more people and we're going
to get behind other stuff that is the
right answer the wrong answer is to stay
in hero mode until you burnout which is
what most people do third mistake bad
delegation most founders have not
managed people before and I certainly
haven't managed managers and so the way
that the bad way you delegate is you say
hey employee we need to do this big
thing you go off and research it come
back to me with all the data and the
trade off I'll make a decision and tell
it to you and then you'll go off
implement it that's how most founders
delegate and that does not make people
feel good and it certainly doesn't scale
a subtle difference but really important
is to say hey you're really smart that's
why I hired you you go off here are the
things to think about here's what I
think but you make this decision I
totally trust you and let me know what
you decide
that's the delegation actually works
because I think because Steve Jobs was
able to get away with the former and
make every decision himself and people
just put up with it and every founder
thinks they're the next Steve Jobs a lot
of people try this but but I for 99.9%
of people
the second method here works a lot
better and then the fourth area is just
a personal organization one when you are
working on products you don't actually
need to be that organized in terms of
how you run the company and how you talk
to you what they're working on but if
you fail to get your own personal
organization system right where you can
keep track in some way of what you need
to do what everybody else was doing and
what you need to follow up with them on
that will come back to bite you so
developing this early as the company
begins to scale is really important to
other things that we hear again and
again from our founders they wish they
had done earlier and that is simply
writing down how you do things and why
you do things these two things the how
and the why are really important in the
early days you just tell everyone
employee when you're like sitting around
having lunch or dinner you know this is
how we think about building product this
is how we push to production you know
this is how we handle customer support
whatever as you get bigger you can't
keep doing that and if you don't do it
someone else is just going to say it but
if you write it down and put it up on a
wiki or whatever that every employee
reads you as the founder get to
basically write the law and if you write
this down it will become long the
company and if you make everyone read
this as the company hires a hundred and
then a thousand employees people will
read this and say all right that's how
we do things if you don't do it it'll be
like random oral tradition of whatever
the hiring manager or their best friend
that they make it their first week in
the company tells them so writing down
how you do things and the why the why is
the cultural values Brian Chesky talked
about this really well every founder I
know wishes that they had written down
both of these the Holland the Y earlier
to just establish it as the company
grows and then this becomes what happens
I think it's one of the highest leverage
you can do that the people don't alright
next HR HR is another thing that most
people correctly ignore in the first
phase of a startup because again it's
not writing code it's not talking to
users but it's a huge mistake to
continue to ignore it and the reason
that I think most founders ignore it is
they have in their mind this idea of
like TV sitcom HR you know awfulness but
it doesn't have to slow you down
actually it speeds you up most founders
will say at a1 side of MS people are our
most important asset and the other side
we don't want any HR so what they mean
is we don't want HR we don't like the
bad kind of TV HR what good HR means is
a few things a clear structure which
already talked about you know a path for
people about how they can evolve their
careers most important one of the most
important things is performance feedback
again this happens organically early on
people know how they're doing as the
company gets to 25 30 45 people that
gets lost and it doesn't have to be
complex it can be super simple but there
should be a way that it happens and it
should be frequent you know people need
to hear pretty quickly how they're doing
and it should tie you know if they're
doing badly to a way you get some out of
company or if they do doing well it
should there should be a clear path to
how to size the compensation and that's
the next thing in the early days of a
startup people's compensation is
whatever they negotiate with the founder
and it's all over the place as you grow
it feels hopelessly corporate but it
really is worth putting in place these
compensation bands so a mid-level
engineer is in this range of senior
engineers in this range here's how you
move from this to this and it keeps
things really fair I someday everyone
will find that everyone else is comp if
it's all over the place it will be a
complete meltdown disaster if you put
these bands in place early it will at
least be fair it will also save you a
lot of crazy negotiation one thing that
I think is really important when it
comes to HR is equity most people get
this right now for the early employees
that give a lot of equity but I think
you should continue to give a lot of
equity all the way through and this is
one place that your investors will
always give you bad advice I think
not YC but all other investors give that
advice here most do you should be giving
out a lot of equity to your employees
now this dilutes everyone Isis to lose
you as the founder and the investors
equally for some reason founders usually
understand this is good investors are
very short-sighted and don't want to
deluge themselves so they'll like fight
you over every equity grant but we've
seen a lot of data at YC now and the
most successful companies and the ones
where the investors do the best end up
giving a lot of stock on to employees
year after year after year
so I tell founders like you should think
about you know for the next 10 years
you're going to be giving out 3 to 5
percent of the company every year
because you just get bigger and bigger
so the individual grants get smaller but
in aggregate it's a lot of stock and I
think this is really important to do if
you value your people you should be
doing this specifically you need to do
this with refresher grants and you
should get a plan in place for this
early you know I think you never want an
employee in a place where they invested
three out of their four years of stock
and they start thinking about leaving so
you should always stay in front of
people's vesting schedules and you know
have a plan early where you have
refresher grants in place there are a
lot of new structures that people have
been using here I personally like
six-year big grants but six years of
vesting because I think these companies
just take a while to build theirs
pyramid vesting where you back away from
one's grant so in year four they get a
lot more of the best in the new year one
there's a concept different names for it
but something like continuous forward
vesting where people's grants are
automatically react every year it's the
same number of shares whatever you
decide get an option management system
in place at about this point the normal
way people do this is just someone keeps
an Excel spreadsheet I have seen
mistakes that have cost employees or
companies tens of millions of dollars
because they didn't get this right so
there's really good option management
systems or software and you should get
those in place around this point the
other sort of HR stuff to touch on there
are a bunch of rules that change around
50 employees common examples that you
have to start
sexual harassment training and diversity
training there's a bunch of others as
well but just put a little pin in your
mind that when you cross 50 employees
there's a new set of HR rules that you
have to comply with monitor your team
for burnout again it's up to product
market fit it's just a sprint now
becomes a marathon at this point you
actually don't want people to work 100
hours a week forever you want them to go
on vacation you want them to have new
challenges and doing these things
and if you let the whole company get
burned out all at once that that is
often a company and means thing this is
also a good time to put in place a
hiring process another thing that most
founders regret is they don't hire as
soon as everything that's working I
think you should hire a full-time
recruiter if you knew this too early
that's bad because you'll hire it too
fast and I usually implode but most
founders get behind the ball on this the
other there are a lot of other sort of
hiring process tips for example I think
most companies even until they get up to
say three or four hundred employees
should announce every offer on some
internal mailing list or something
before they make it because like half
the time you do that someone in the
company will know something good or bad
about that employee and the companies
that I know that I've instituted this
had been really happy also a good time
to have a program in place to ramp up
employees so when someone starts you
know what is their first week look like
how do they get how do they get spun up
how do they learn every single aim to
learn are they going to have a buddy
that's going to think through them this
is going to help them think through kind
of everything about the company here is
one that you actually do need to think
about before the 12 to 24 months mark
which is diversity on the team
the most common place this comes up
honestly is people that hire you know
all guys on their engineering team for
the first 15 or 20 people and at that
point you get a culture in place that
sort of takes on a life of its own and
most founders that I've spoken to that I
made this mistake regret it and they
wished they had hired some diversity of
perspective on the team earlier on
engineering seems about the only place
where it comes up but that's where you
see it most often and if you get this
right early you'll be able to grow the
team much more quickly over over the
long term
the other thing to think about is what
happens to your early employees so a
common situation that happens is the
company evolved past the early employees
you know the company so like you hire an
engineer who's a really great engineer
but then if the engineering team grows
you need a VP of engineering the early
engineer wants to be the VP of
engineering you can't do that and but
you don't the early employee to leave
they're an important important part of
the culture they know a lot people love
them and so I think you want to be very
proactive about this you know you want
to like think about what's the path for
my first 10 or 15 employees going to be
as the company grows and then just talk
to them about it very directly be
upfront you know I wanted exits and
doughnuts I want to talk about sort of
where you want to see your career go
inside of this company all right so
company productivity this is something
that you don't need to think about in
the early days because small teams are
just sort of naturally productive most
of the time but as you grow it the
productivity I think goes down with the
square of the number of employees if you
don't make an effort because it's sort
of one of these like connections between
those every pair of people has
communication overhead and so if you
don't start thinking about the systems
that you're going to put in place when
the company is 25 to 50 people to stay
productive as you grow things will grind
to a halt faster than you can imagine
the single word that matters most I
think to keep the company productive as
it grows is alignment the reason
companies become unproductive is people
are either not on the same page and you
know don't know what the same priorities
are or they're actively working against
each other
which is obviously worse but if you can
keep the entire company aligned in the
same direction you'll have won well over
half of the battle and and the way to
start with this is just a very clear
roadmap and goals everyone in the
company should know what the roadmap for
the next three or six months or a year
depending on where the company is in its
lifecycle looks like you know a classic
test that I love to give is if I walk
to accompany getting beginning to
struggle with these scaling issues I'll
ask the founders like if I walked around
and pulled 10 random employees and asked
them what the top 3 goals for the
company are right now would they all say
the same thing and a hundred percent of
the time the founder says yes of course
they would and I go do it and 100
percent of the time
no two employees even say the same three
top three goals in order and the
founders can never believe it because
they're like well I announce it in all
hands like three months ago what our
goals were going to be and how can I not
remember but it's really important to
keep reiterating the message about the
roadmap and the goal and almost no
founder does this enough and if you do
it you know the company will say you
know all right these are our goals we
understand that we're going to get them
done I know self-organize around that
but if people don't know what the
roadmap or the goals are it won't happen
we already talked about figuring out
your values early but I want to
reiterate that because that also really
helped the company make the right
decisions if everyone knows what the
framework to decide is they'll make
hopefully the same decisions if they're
smart people you want to continue to be
run by great products and not process
for its own sake this is a fine fine
line because you do need to put some
process in place but you never want to
put process in place that rewards the
process the focus has to always be on
great product one easy way to do this
that a lot of companies try is they just
say we're going to ship something every
day
and if you do that you know there's at
least two continued focus on delivery
and then transparency and rhythm and how
you communicate are really important
most founders wait way too long on these
but having a management meeting every
week of just the people that report
directly to the founder of the CEO
critical all-hands meetings not quite
sure how often is optimal for those at
least once a month where you go through
the results and the roadmap with the
entire company really important and then
you know doing a plan every quarter of
what we're going to get done over the
next three months and how that fits into
our goals for the year also becomes
really important I put offsides up there
because I don't think people do those
nearly enough
a surprising number of the successful
companies we've been involved with do a
lot of off sites where they'll take
their best people for a weekend to a
cabin in the woods or somewhere and just
talk about what do we want to be when we
grow up what are our most important
things to be doing what are we not doing
that we should be doing but get people
out of the office and out of the
day-to-day everyone I know that does
those thinks they're well worth the time
so the goal in all of this productivity
planning is that you're trying to build
a company that creates a lot of value
over a long period of time and the long
period of time is what's important here
you can avoid all of this and just like
with the authority of the founder make
sure the company ships a great next
version but that won't work for version
10 and won't work for version 11
I really believe that the single hardest
thing in business is building a company
that does repeatable innovation and just
has this ongoing culture of excellence
as it grows if you look at the examples
of this most companies fail here most
companies do one great thing where the
founder just pushes to get it done and
then don't innovate that well on
follow-on products and it really takes
founders that think about how I'm going
to do this second thing this really hard
thing to get something like an apple
that can turn out great products for 30
or 40 years or longer
all right these are super tactical
mechanics this is this is definitely to
just put on a list and remember these
things for later all right in the early
days people basically ignore all
accounting and they have like maybe if
they're lucky a shoebox full of receipts
they certainly don't have anything that
looks like a financial report this is a
good time to get it in place you know
when things are working so month 18 or
whatever you can do this with an
outsourced person just say you know what
we want like to get our books in order
you want to start getting audits every
year we want to start a relationship
with an accounting firm easy to do
definitely worth it this is also a good
time to collect your legal documents
because it's easy to fix things now so
if you actually assign someone to go
through and collect every agreement the
company has ever signed then when your
land
Lord tries to screw you out of your
lease and no one can find a lease which
happens like half the time somehow
someone will be able to find it all so
you're almost certainly missing
something you know some employee didn't
sign there
PII a or whatever and you'll find it now
it's easy to fix now it gets really hard
to fix like in the middle of your next
round of financing so again this is time
to bring like a little bit of an order
to chaos SF stock is a special class of
stock for founders that the founders can
sell in a later round without messing up
the common stock valuation it used to be
that most people set this up right when
they started the company founders fund
sort of popularized this which is why
it's called SF stock but it became a
really bad signal right founders that
were obsessed with their own personal
liquidity when the company had nothing
turned out to like sale most of the time
and so investors learned that if
founders pushed on this in the seed
round it was very very bad design most
founders don't actually want to sell
stock until the company is worth like a
billion dollars or something like that
so I think you can actually safely set
this up after things start working in
the next financing around and then you
can sell it two three four years down
the road but it's a good thing to
remember by the time you get to the B
round IP trademarks and pad ah actually
just IP and trademarks so you have 12
months after you announce something if
you want to patent it and if you miss
that window it's very hard to do so
eleven months after you launch or first
publicly talk about your doing is a good
time to file provisional patents we
recommend people just file provisional
patents all that does is like hold your
place in line of the Patent Office and
it gives you another year to decide if
you want to patent something or not it
only costs about a thousand dollars
it takes away less effort than a full
patent and most of the time you'll know
whether or not you need the full patent
a year later but if you just do this one
step you'll always have the option it's
also a good time to file trademarks for
the u.s. major international markets
again if you don't do this at this stage
most people end up regretting it and
while you're at it a good time to grab
all the domains
fpn a good time also I think to think
about someone to start doing FPA I think
most companies don't end up realizing
where the knobs on that financial model
are until far too late and I think it
turns out that if you have someone build
a really great model at the business and
buy really great
apparently Roelof Botha who is a PayPal
CFO and built their FPA model the top
they like the top sheet of his
spreadsheet with 1,500 line just as the
level of the detail people build these
too but you can really optimize the
business and understand it at a level
that I think most people totally miss
most people don't hire someone like this
until they're many hundreds of employees
I think it's worth hiring earlier
another thing that I think is worth
hiring earlier but almost no one does is
a full time fundraiser let's say you
hire someone like really really great
and their full time job is to raise
money for the company you hire them
after your B round and you say you know
what by the time we raise our C round we
want the valuation to be double what
would have been otherwise you almost
certainly get better results than if you
hire an investment banker or someone
else if it's just someone internal the
company and you end up Ain way less
money and take like literally half the
dilution so I think this is one of these
like slightly non-obvious optimizations
that people just fail to make tax
structuring so this is another thing
most once things are working it would be
worth you spending a little bit of time
thinking about how you set up the tax
structure for the company I confess I
don't know a lot about the details here
because I just find it personally really
boring but like somehow if you assign
all the IPE to like some corporation in
Ireland that licenses it back to the US
corporation you end up paying like no
tax no corporate tax but I know you can
only do that like relatively early on
and this ends up being a huge issue for
companies that don't do it that could be
with companies that do do it you know
once they're big public companies so
that's worth doing a lot of people
throughout the class have talked about
your own psychology as a founder
here's what they haven't said it gets
worse not better as the company grows
you continue to us what the highs are
better but the lows keep getting worse
and you really want to think about this
early on and just be aware this is going
to happen and try to try to manage your
own psychology through the expanding
swings that it's going to go through
another thing that happens as you begin
to be successful as you go from being
someone that most people rooted for kind
of the underdog to someone that a lot of
people start hating on and you know you
see this first in internet commenters
who will be like I can't believe the
shitty company raised money if I can
suck like awful and it only bothers you
a little bit but then like journalists
that you kind of care about start
writing this and just goes on and on
this also will go on and on as you get
more and more successful and you just
make peace with this early but if you
don't it will bother you all the way
through this is also a good time to
start thinking about how long of a
journey this is going to be very few
founders think long term most founders
think kind of a year in advance and they
think that you know what in three years
I'm going to sell my company and either
I'm going to become a VC or some of the
beach or something because so few people
make an actual long-term commitment to
what they're building
the ones that do have a huge advantage
there they're in a very rarefied class
and so this is a good time to like sit
around with your co-founders and decide
you know what we're going to work on
this for a very long time and we're
going to build a strategy that assumes
that we're going to be doing this for
the next ten years just thinking that
way alone I think it's probably a very
high leverage thing you can do for
success take vacation another common
thing that we see is founders will run
their business for three or four years
without ever taking you know more than a
day of vacation and that works for like
a year or two years something like that
it really leads to nasty burn or not if
you don't do it losing focus is another
way that founder
get off track I actually think this is a
symptom of burnout when you get really
burned out on running the business you
want to do easier things or sort of more
gratifying things you want to go to
conferences and have people tell you how
great you are you know you want to do
all these things that are not actually
building the business and the most
common post YC failure case for the
companies we fund is that they're
incredibly focused during YC on their
company and then after they start doing
a lot of other things you know they they
advise companies they go to conferences
whatever focus is what made you
successful in the first place
there are a lot of reasons people lose
focus but fight against that really
really hard this is the special case of
focus as you start to do well you will
start to get a bunch of potential
acquires sniffing around and it's very
gratifying and you're like wow I could
be so rich and I'd be so cool and M&A
negotiations feel really fun
this is one of the biggest killers of
companies is that they entertain
acquisition conversations you you
distract yourself you get demoralized if
it doesn't happen if an offer does come
in it's really low you've already like
mentally thought that you're done and so
you take the offer it's a general rule
don't start any acquisition conversation
unless you're willing to sell ah for a
pretty low number don't ever just check
it hoping that you're going to have the
one miracle hi offer if that's going to
happen you'll know because they'll just
make you a big offer before you can meet
them but this this is a big company
killer and then just as a reminder to
everybody this thing that kills startups
at some level is the founders giving up
so sometimes you should quit but if you
miss manage your own psychology and you
quit like when you shouldn't that is
what kills companies I mean that is that
is the sort of final cause of death most
of these startups and so if you can
manage your own psychology in a way that
you don't quit don't get to a place
where you need to quit or give up on the
startup you'll be in a far far better
place
so marketing to PR is something that we
tell companies to ignore for a long time
everyone thinks in the early days that
the press is going to be what saves them
we tell them all the time it doesn't
work that way
it's definitely true you know press is
not what's going to save your startup
but as you start to be successful this
is some of the founders themselves need
to spend time on so once your product is
working switched from not caring about
this to caring about it a little bit and
the two most important things for the
founder to do the founders to do figure
out the key messaging yourself never
outsource this to your head of marketing
or PR firm you founders have to figure
out what the message of the company is
going to be and once you set that it
kind of sticks very hard to change this
once the press decides how they're going
to talk about you the other thing is
getting to know key journalists yourself
PR firms will always try to prevent you
from doing this because they need to
have a reason to exist and so they're
like we're going to handle a
relationship with a journalist we'll
just bring in for interviews no
journalist wants to talk to a PR flack
ever there's so much more happy they
just hear from a founder I think the
biggest PR hack you can do is to not
hire a PR firm just pick three or four
journalists that you develop really
close relationships with that like you
to understand you that you get and then
you contact them yourself they will
cover every story you ever give them and
they'll actually pay attention and get
to know you and care about the company
this is so much better than the normal
strategy of having a PR firm blast 200
contacts that never read their emails
with every piece of news so this is
something that I think is important to
start doing this is also the time in a
company when business development starts
to matter and so in the early days you
can basically ignore anything that would
be like doing deals
except maybe fundraising and sales you
know this is the time when they're
important and and everything are many
things that you do like even fundraising
it falls under the category of doing
deals
so there are here's my one minute crash
course on this there are five points
that I think are important to understand
here
we've talked about this a lot nothing
well nothing will matter if you don't
build a great product so assume that
you've done this before you go try and
get anyone to do anything with you
developing a personal connection with
anyone you're trying to do any sort of
big deal with is really important for
whatever reason most founders fail to do
this or many founders fail to do this
but no one wants to feel like they're
this transactional thing that you're
using them to get distribution for your
product or the raise of money or
whatever and so figuring out some way to
actually care about this person and care
about what you're doing with them and
not give them you're not paying your own
mind not just view them it's one-off
transaction yes actually care about then
what they're going to get out of this
competitive dynamics so this is like
basic principle of negotiation most
funders will learn this the first time
in fundraising but it actually matters
for everything the way you get deals
done the way you get good terms is to
have a competitive situation you know if
you don't do this deal with party a you
can do with party B it's not always an
option but it usually is and this is
like the single thing that makes deals
happen it makes deals move Tyler talked
about persistence the last lecture so I
want to hit on that again too much other
than to say you have to go beyond your
comfort point here most of the time with
the founder and then the fifth point is
you have to ask for what you want this
is another thing I still have trouble
with this and certainly most of the
founders we do have you know if you want
something in a deal just ask for it most
of the time you know you won't get left
out of the room and you might get it but
you have to be like at some point you
actually have to say you know this is
what I would like you to do even if it
feels aggressive or an overreach or
whatever so I want to close this part of
the talk with an image one of the Airbnb
founders drew this on like a business
card or something for another founder
that was starting a company and then I
saw it once and took a picture of it
because I thought it was such a good
summary and what he had tried to draw
here was the Y Combinator process as he
remembered it and I love it because it's
like so simple and it looks so doable
when it's written on a business card but
you're trying to find product market fit
you know you're trying to build a
product and you're trying to close the
gap between those two years the only way
to do that is to go off and meet the
people you cannot do this without
getting really really close to your
users and then he drew this graph that
sort of on a whiteboard at YC and gotten
kind of like one of the YC rites of
passage but that's the graph of how
adoption goes for a new company so you
launch in the press you get a huge spike
it falls off to nothing at some point at
least one point things look like they're
going to completely die and kind of dip
below the x-axis they recover a little
bit you have this long long long trough
of sorrow before things work in air
being abused case it was a thousand days
before the graph started taking upward
if these Wiggles of false hope and then
finally finally finally things start to
grow three years later so starting a
startup ends up being this very long
process it is you know it can be really
rewarding it's definitely long but it is
doable and that's what I love about that
drawing so with that I think I've got
ten minutes left I can answer questions
on this or anything else in the course
that we've covered if anyone has them
yeah really figures that Sarah C wasn't
won't you just tell people they're very
much human so here is via the question
is how do you square the device to
diversity being important with earlier
speakers saying you want people that are
very similar the difference what you
want is you want diversity of
backgrounds but you don't want diversity
of vision like where companies get in
trouble is when they have people that
think very differently about what the
companies should be doing or don't work
well together you don't want that you do
want to hire people that you know and
that you trust and that you can work
with but if everyone on the team comes
from exactly the same background you and
you do end up developing somewhat of a
monoculture which often causes problems
down the road not always
companies have been successful with that
so what we tell people is hire people
that you know and that you've worked
with before but try too hot try to hire
people that are complementary and align
towards the same goal not people that
are exactly the same because you just
get a better skillset how to keep track
productivity systems so the one I use
which I actually in course really well
is I keep one piece of paper with my
goals for sort of a three to twelve
month time frame and I look at that
everyday and then separately I keep one
one page for every day of my short term
goals for that day and so if I need to
do something in like a week I just flip
forward seven pages and write it down
and then I also keep a list of every
person and what they're working on what
I tell them and what I talked to them
about what we talked about last time so
every time I sit down with someone I
kind of have the full state and a list
of things for that person that works
really well yeah yeah the advice for how
to feel grateful yeah yeah great
question how to feel gracefully
so most jobs fail and Silicon Valley
almost goes too far and how much it
loves failure failure still sucks you
should still try not to fail and this
whole like thing of like ah failure is
great I don't agree with but it will
happen to most people most of the time
and it's a very forgiving environment as
long as you are upfront about it an
ethical and don't let anyone get into a
bad situation so if you're failing first
of all you should tell your investors
and second of all you should not totally
around the money what you don't want is
a blow-up with a bunch of you know debts
with the company oh and everyone you
know showing up to work one day and the
door being locked you'll know when
you're failing you'll know when the
company's things just aren't going to
work
and you should tell your investors like
hey sorry this isn't going to work no
one will be surprised like I expect to
lose my or I'm willing to lose my money
on every investment I ever make I know
that happens most of the time and the
winners pay for it you know still with a
factor of 100 so it's okay
no one people will be very understanding
and supportive but you want to tell
people early you don't want to surprise
them and you want you don't want to like
let your employees get shocked on the
other end of the job you know you want
to shut the companies down in a graceful
way help them find jobs make sure you
give them two or four weeks of severance
payment so that they're not suffering a
cash flow problem all that stuff is
pretty important yeah he majored fathers
of Athenian life hungry
how many immigrant founders that we seen
in Y Combinator in the last batch I
think it probably went up for this next
batch in the last batch forty-one
percent of the founders we founded were
born outside us from 30 different
countries yeah pretty big percentage
what do you think what other motivations
is darkness apart from the valley where
do I think our other good places to
start a startup well I still think the
valley is the best by a very significant
margin but I think it's finally maybe
beginning to weaken a little bit because
the costs have just gotten so out of
control to be clear if I was going to
start a company I still wouldn't think
about it I would still pick Silicon
Valley and I think if you look at the
data of companies over the last few
years that I still wins by a lot but
Seattle la lots of places outside the US
I think all of these make sense
I hesitate to make recommendations or
expense on enough time in the cities to
really have an intuitive feel but like I
mean you know as well as I do the common
ones people talk about startup hubs and
I just I can't make a personal
recommendation they're all hire session
feel and
when should the founders think about
hiring a professional CEO never you if
you look at the most successful
companies in tech they are run by their
founders for a very long time sometimes
forever and sometimes even hire
professional CEO and then realize that
that is not going to like build a great
company and so like Larry Page came back
to be CEO again I think if you don't
want to be the long-term CEO of a
company you probably shouldn't start one
I'm not totally sure about that I think
there are exceptions but generally that
the transition I talked about today is
you go from building a great product to
building a great company being a founder
you know for nine of the ten years is
going to be about building that great
company and if you're not excited about
doing that I think you should think hard
about about it yeah what are the most
common is most alarming water size you
looking for we try to make this ship
building great products great companies
what are the the most common mistakes to
make when you're shifting towards
building a great company I think I went
through most of them here I tried to put
everything in here that I see people on
my side most of the time yeah they're a
way to get involved in the white home
community or getting it is there a way
to get involved with YC before getting
funded no and intentionally not actually
I'll say the one thing you can do is if
you work at a YC company and then later
apply I think that probably like well
not probably that definitely if you get
a good recommendation from those
founders will help with YC so you know
working at a YC company helped but
there's not much you can do to help them
that's intentional like there is no pre
startups in the way that there is
pre-med you should just focus on
whatever you're doing and then when you
start to start up there are things like
YC and others that are structured to
help you most of the founders we fund we
don't know at all before we do it you
know you don't you really don't need to
get to know us or get involved we're all
good that way yeah
now how did it get included in a white
community getting across any Harvard to
is the criteria you excuse to retire the
question is what what criteria do we use
the pick start up and has it gotten
harder
has it changed you know we did two
things that we need to see are are good
founders and a good idea and without
both of those we we won't fund a company
but that hasn't changed like that is
that has always been the case the
applicant pool to YC has grown quite a
bit but most of our a lot of the growth
is you know people that shouldn't be
starting startups anyway probably that
are just doing it because it's sort of
the cool thing though so you know if
you're really passionate about an idea
and the idea is good and you're you know
smart and good things done you're
executing and I still think you have a
very reasonable shot iyc even though the
headline numbers bigger yeah a certain
market that you're really excited about
that don't necessarily know about yet is
there a certain hat you recommend or
ways sure if there's a market that
you're excited about but don't know a
lot about yet what should you do two
schools of thought on this one is to
just jump right in
learn it as you go that's worked a lot
of times the other is to go work at a
company in the space or do something in
in the market for you know a year or two
years I leaned slightly towards the
second but as long as you're willing to
really learn and really study and really
get uncomfortably close to your users
either case will work and I don't even
think it's that much of a disadvantage
right
I think all things being equal I would
go spend a couple of years learning
about it in detail but I don't think you
have to yeah yeah how efficient is to
licensure - yeah so I think I could use
a fantastic job in promoting propulsion
in Silicon Valley experimental investor
actually 90 methods we also like P in a
personal few years the hardware minuses
that you know you guys have 180
companies this year coming to the market
angel diagram it's hard to follow each
other what you have angular you think
this will create some some people would
walk away from I say because he cannot
model structure but medical company and
relay devotees because how it has to be
very polished and the fun has to do
think over a lot about idea
these are colorful evenings on your real
under the government for a lot is mostly
all easy to access the capital all right
so I think the question is yes do I
think investors are going to fund less
YC companies as we grow no definitely
not like certainly the trend in this is
the other way we have more and more
investors saying that you know half
their portfolio with now YC companies
and they look forward to the day where
it's three quarters no I don't think
it's problem at all I think that it's
like so not on my top 100 problem list
the opposite of that may be all right
one more question yeah
when should a group of founders raised
and seed money this is a great question
I think that I think that in general
it's nice to wait until you have the
idea figured out and initial signs of
promise before you raise money raising
money puts some pressure on the company
some time pressure and once you've
raised money you can't be in this
exploratory phase indefinitely you and
you end up having to rush and so like if
you haven't raised mine and your idea is
not working you can you know like flail
around and pivot until you really hit on
the thing that's working but if you've
raised money and your idea doesn't work
you're in this like oh [ __ ] moment ain't
half the pivot and you pivot to whatever
the first vaguely plausible ideas and
that's bad so I think if you can wait to
raise any outside capital more than say
like 100 or 200 thousand dollars if
necessary but ideally not even that
until things are working or at least
pointed in the direction of working
you're way better off all right thank
you all very much this was fun
[Applause]